ist wahrscheinlich
die bestgeschützte Einrichtung des
Planeten gegen Raketenangriffe
Drohnenangriffe und als ich mir die
Videos angeschaut habe wie sie alle
wahrscheinlich gesehen haben vergangenen
Abend
da wurde doch klar dass das keinen
Schlag war der das Ziel hatte den Kreml
zu vernichten oder Präsident Putin zu
töten das ist wahrscheinlich ein Versuch
des gremmels und auch ein ziemlich ja
schwach ausgeführt dafür versucht um
Russland hier als Opfer darstellen zu
können denn die Menschen können dann
sagen wir müssen zurückschlagen und es
gab so viele Probleme in Russland in den
vergangenen Jahr eigentlich über die
gesamte Dauer des Krieges und die
Antwort die Reaktion auf diese Drohne
Attacke war zu schnell zu vorbereitet
und passte nicht zum ganzen Rest
natürlich ist das erst einmal eine
Peinlichkeit für Präsident Putin